bien bonjour à tous le bureau politique
s'est donc réuni sous la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy
il a pris acte des résultats du premier
tour des élections régionales marquées
par trois phénomènes
premièrement une forte abstention un
français sur deux ne s'est pas déplacé
deuxièmement une poussée des votes
extrêmes et puis enfin troisièmement un
effondrement de la gauche
alors ces résultats nous le pensons
exprime une profonde crise de confiance
et un besoin de changement dont chaque
responsable politique doit pouvoir
mesurer la gravité
à l'issue de ce premier tour les
républicains et le centre constitue la
seule force politique en mesure de
répondre à cette aspiration de
changement en écartant bien sûr les
options les plus extrêmes qui conduirait
notre pays
al aventure et au désordre elle n'y
parviendra qu'en restant fidèle à ses
convictions et à ses valeurs
elle est jouée en se laissant aller à
des combinaisons partisane qui ne ferait
que ruines et un peu plus la confiance
des français
le bureau politique demande donc à tous
ces candidats qui ont mené campagne au
premier tour de façon courageuse dans
des circonstances difficiles de se
maintenir pour continuer le combat
politique au service du pays et au
service de leur région
le bureau politique des républicains
exclut donc toujours très tôt de fusion
totale et ans tout accord qui donnerait
le sentiment aux français qu'on voudrait
leur confisquer l'élection par des
arrangements tactique conclu dans leur
dos il appelle tous les électeurs quel
que soit leur choix du premier tour et
en particulier tout naturellement ceux
qui ont choisi l'abstention à se réunir
autour des listes des républicains et du
centre pour construire l'avenir
cette motion a fait l'objet d'un vote au
sein du bureau politique qui a été
approuvé à l'unanimité moins deux